次に同じことを単純バージョンでいきます
今までなんかすごい難しい論理的なバージョンで
単純バージョンだから
これで理解できると思います
人は常に変わるのに 我々は変わらない名前でその人は認識する
それは単純バージョンで
生まれた時の田中さんが ４０歳
８０歳になっても田中さんですが
決して同じ人間人ではありませんでしょ
それぐらいわかるでしょ
生まれた赤ちゃんに田中と名前付けちゃうと
それ死ぬまで田中でしょうに
でもずっと変わってるでしょうに
その品物は １０歳になったら全く別な品物でしょうに
おかしいでしょうに 品物は完全に変わってるのに
同じ名前で売ってるということが
そこで仮に人は変わると名前も変えてみましょう
仮に 物は変わるとその物の名前も変えてみます
赤ちゃんに田中さんと言ったら １０
歳の子には田中さんと言わないこと
名前変える 田中さんがBというあるものを欲しくなるんです
それが自分のものになったら幸福だろうと推測するんです
田中さんが 何か見て B
ってものを見て あ Bが私にあったら幸せだろうと思っちゃうんです
しかし 田中さんが止まらず変わるから
少々時間経って変わっていくんですね
欲しいと思っても時間止まりませんだからもう田中さんも変わっちゃうんですね
その変わった人を中田さんと言いましょう
もう田中さんがいない
もうもう二度とないんで
もう変わっちゃったんです
中田さんがBではなく
Cを自分のものにするんです
Bも変わっちゃったんだから
同時に それで中田さんがCを自分のものにする
これ 田中さんがBを欲しがったんです
その結果 中田さんがCをもらうことになっちゃったんです
物は物Bが物Cに変わってるんですからね
もう それで私が言いたいのは
田中さんがBが欲しがったところで
中田さんがCがもらってどうなるんでしょうかと
中田さんに本当にCが必要でしょうか？と
それって全然関係なく
だから我々の世界で言えば
なんか家にいると蕎麦食べたいなと
これ 家にいる時の要求ですよ
そこで家に蕎麦がないんだから
まあ着替えてもう出て行って
自転車でも車でも電車でも出て行って
気に入ってる蕎麦屋さんに行ってもう違う人間なんですけど
違う人間が蕎麦食べても希望叶ってないんです
家にいた時 瞬間の人が蕎麦食べた食べたかったんです B
を欲しがった田中さんにBを得ることができたならば楽しいはずでしたが
田中さんもBも絶えず変わるから
それを得ることは不可能です
だから期待するものは決して得られないんです
田中さんがBが欲しがったらパシッとBがもらったならば楽しいんですよ
しかし これは不可能です
田中さんがずっと変わるんですよ
Bもずっと変わるでしょうに
せいぜいできることは中田さんがCを得ることですね
せいぜい中田さんにCを得ることができるだけの話で
これでは話になりませんよ
不安になるんですよ 子供がお腹がすいたと泣いていると
もうおもちゃあげて これかわいいでしょとかあげちゃっても
問題解決してないんです
子供はお腹が空いてないといないいないばあと言って笑って笑わせたら OK
もうミルクあげなくても大丈夫って
こんなのありえません
だから我々はずっと期待あるでしょうに
期待っていうのは決して論理的には叶うものじゃないんです
だから期待は叶わないんです
それはこのシンプル単純バージョンで理解してください
しかし 中田さんにビーもシーも必要ありません
でしょう 田中さんがビーが欲しかったんですけど
中田さんになってからはね
ビーもシーもではなくて
もしかするとエフのエフというものが欲しいかもしれませんよ
私は別な例も考えたんですけど
書いてないんですけど
例えば二十歳の男の子が恋人を作ったりする
それであっちこっち遊びに行きたいでしょうに
そうするといい車があったら
まあ女の人を入れて いろんなところで
どこでしたっけ？みんな行くところありますね
お台場とかね まあそういうところに行って遊びたいんですね
しかし もう二十歳だから金あるわけないでしょう
その時は得られませんね
期待するものを そこで同じ人と結婚して
仕事もして 金も貯めて
子供も一人ぐらい生まれていて
それでいくらか預金があって車を買うんです
その時は二十歳の時欲しかった同じ型の同じ車かもしれませんだけど
あの楽しみは得られませんよ
もうあの女の子はいません
今いるのは子供と戦っている
もう一人の女性お母さんなんですよ
もう旦那のこと構っている場合もないんです
お前黙っていろというところなんです
うるさいと だから病院に行かなくちゃいけないんだから
もう早く車出せと言うんです
もし形の時はあったならば
最高の幸せでしたでしょうに
でも実際はそうならないんですね
時間ずれます だから二十歳の若者が車が欲しかった
それで一児の父親は車が買ったと
話にならんでしょう それは私がお腹が空いていると
佐藤さんがじゃあご飯食べますよと言ったっても
話にならんでしょうね
まあ私は子供相手ならそのゲームやりますよ
この心理のゲームをね
まあ子供はわかるんですよ
その場合は 子供はなんとかあのなんとか食べたいので言ったら
じゃあ私は昨日食べましたから大丈夫ですって言うんです
子供はどう反応するのかと
だって私は昨日それ食べたんだよ
だからいりませんよと
自由に子供に言うんです
子供は だから子供はその時はこの仏教の世界に入るしかないんです
で 子供は文句を言うんです
だから親が私が頭が悪いと思っちゃいますけど
親が頭が悪いんで だから親に育てる子供みんな頭悪いんだからね
私に絡む子供たちはなかなか大したもんですよ
そのエネルギーある子しかあまりついてはこないんですけどもね
むちゃくちゃもう知恵開発するようにさせるんです
ただ 田中さんがBを欲しがったから
その流れで中田さんがCを取ってしまっただけ
同じ流れで だから二十歳の男の子が
もうもう例えばアウディの車が欲しかったんですけど
これで三十五歳で一児の父になったところでアウディの車買うと
その時も車は違うでしょうに
もう十五年も経ってますからね
だから決して満足できなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで何の満足も期待
願望も成就もありません
期待 願望の成就なんかはね
札はあるんだけど あれは札だけ
実際は起こりません あるのは何だこれ？という事件のことだけですよ
ですから 我々はなんだこれ？という状態で生きているでしょ
こんなはずではなかったとかね
やっぱりダメだとかね
ずっと口癖あるんですよ
それを それは無常の流れで起きる当然な結果なんです
結局残るのはそれ なんだこれやと
あれも芸術家の人が言ってる
なんだこれはって意味とは違うんです
ですから 不満は決して満たせません
不満というのは満たせないものになるんです
そんなもんで またありますかね
だいたいもうそろそろ終わるとは思いますけど
まあ一応結論出してます